[Music]
anyways dior
yeah dude
um so [ __ ] la dude
i mean you put on dior and stood next to
a big sign that said dior and then you
tagged them like we get it bro you wore
dior
yeah
i mean i i'm i you said i was right when
i was when i was at this i was laughing
because i was like i can't believe how
la this actually is
and this joke just keeps yeah
being cemented yeah harder and harder
well why would you set up this wall
that's like a really weird thing you
think i did this yeah what's really
weird to do dude that'd be so funny why
would you put this in front of your
house that's so sweet thank you so much
dior for inviting me
it's just in my studio
now this [ __ ] was actually crazy i
didn't know what to do of course it's a
[ __ ] photo wall there's like 9 000
cameras in front of it it's just funny
because so i show up and they're like
yeah you got to do my pr ladies like you
got to do the photo wall and i was like
yeah i
know you're like oh i know i was like
trust me
this is my first rodeo okay yeah so
we're in line for this [ __ ] and everyone
who's more famous just cuts
yeah and so it's like i'm waiting for
like 45 minutes and these like people
with who are like more important are
like bryce hall
actually yes they're all just cutting in
front they're like their pr person's
like we got to take it first and
everyone's like all right yeah i get it
there's a clear hierarchy here and it
was like
like act like serious actors that were
there like michael b jordan was there
wow and the girl that one from one in
front of me was christina
something i forget what show
christina applegate can you look her up
hendricks christina hendricks what show
is she in mad men aguilera christina
richie
christina richie yeah so she's right in
front of me right she walks in front of
the cameras and it's just like
a flurry of flashes
like i've never it looked like a rave it
was like christina over here please
[Music]
and then there's a second group and she
goes over and the same thing happens and
then i'm next and i walk up and all of
them are like busy looking at the
picture of christian they thought of
christina and they look up and they see
me they're like oh
literally like one flash like one of the
people stopped to take a picture of me
and it was that picture and they're like
can you say your name in front of the
camera into the camera and i was like
it's cody koh and they're like what
i was like cody co
they're like okay thanks and i walk in
front of the second group not a single
person took my picture yeah [ __ ] so like
that's why i look so awkward because
it's like it's a tense i don't know how
to there's two kids one in front of me
they're both models
and they go up and immediately they're
just like
in their element yeah you know the other
feeder thing they're doing this one of
the guys was going like this
and the guy goes can we get a smile
let's get a big smile he goes no smiles
and he goes i'm sorry no smiles
kept going and i was like that was
insane that was la as [ __ ] la as [ __ ]
the guy told me to smile i went
wow
wow i showed him all my teeth yeah
let's get a smile sure
loser i'm a [ __ ] loser
no smiles
that's the sickest thing ever i'm
resisting
laughing my [ __ ] ass off dude no
smiles
dude just to have the i don't know if
it's lack of self-awareness or
confidence what is no that's confidence
is it confidence yeah i mean i do say
that [ __ ] the cash cash will be like why
don't you smile i'd be like no there's
cash though like we're talking like
there's like real photography 30 like
a liquid
liquid death can just comes from behind
the camera
yeah no you're right
yeah i'm talking real photographer
event i like that the bonus episode's
getting mean now yeah
makes it better yeah i agree this whole
thing was uh truly an experience
for me right like i i really didn't feel
like i had any place there i really was
honored that i got invited yeah tony
hawk was there
which i was like legitimately star
struck he walked by and i was like
you know you should have did
when you walked out in front of all the
photographers i think you could walk out
and go hey no no no no photos and then
posing and just staring at them no
photos remember this and then doing that
same pose grab the bag
tightly by the way i was white knuckling
that [ __ ] yeah so this is this is the
best part right like
i obviously i posted this picture and
i'm getting roasted in my in my dms
because i just you're not supposed to
hold it that's just what [ __ ] happens
yeah no people were like dude what is
that fit
you think
they dress me
yeah
i just love that they gave you running
shoes i mean they're christian dior
[ __ ] shoes cds
yeah the balenciaga stock exchange one
was hilarious so great
i think it's sick dude i hope
dawg can you imagine floor trading and
these people show up
like damn are they buying corn futures
or like
yo that walk is horrifying bro
the bdsm mask [ __ ] is so crazy to me
i'm sure that a couple people saw that
were horny
it was like yo
just bricked up
the new york's talking can i get in one
of those
are we uh
is there like a fan experience what are
we doing here everybody
i need that i don't know what it is
about bdsms they
they make me feel worse than like
watching like gore yeah yeah see i hate
this
[Laughter]
this whole vibe like that one like that
valdo looking mask right there with the
buckles on the side of the head oh look
at that one with the tongue
with the what the [ __ ] is this they put
poop in that bag and then you can
this one log yeah
[Laughter]
i need to breathe in the fumes oh we are
scaring the hose away every
episode man sorry
now go to the one with the belt buckles
scroll up
that [ __ ]
yeah that is man you straight up are
wearing
a [ __ ] louie boot like the fact that
someone could just like grab you by that
ratchet strap and just like drag your
head around and you can't see who it is
or where you're going yeah
this [ __ ] is so hot what
yeah it was it was cool man it's funny
because i was there
like youtube
invited me to the park
so part of it is like
like vlogging it that was part of it
it's like oh you gotta show video
footage and everything so
and then like the show ended and
this person from dr came up was like
come with me backstage we gotta talk to
the creative director for the makeup oh
and i was like what
like i just didn't know why i was there
right that's basically the gist of it is
like i have no idea how like there are
this world is such a
world that people know and like i it's
so foreign to me everything to do with
yeah like high fashion like that yeah so
we went and we went upstairs and we're
like they're like entered us to this guy
and we're like are we supposed to be
filming i don't know what we're supposed
to be doing we're like hey so what was
the inspiration for this and he was like
telling us it was just crazy i don't
know were you just like nodding your
head yeah just like okay he's like he
was an anime thing we wanted to go with
anime and the backdrop was gonna be
green then it was blue
and the whole time i was just like i
don't know why i'm here yeah for sure
have you seen crank yeah yeah
now that [ __ ] that's a good ass that's
art that should be your next catwalk
like crank
that would actually be sick
you